this is where Simon Chang was due to
arrive 12 days ago on a train from
mainland China he never made it to Hong
Kong
the last thing he messaged his
girlfriend according to local media was
ready to pass through the border pray
for me
we haven't been able to independently
verify the messages he has apparently
been detained in China since then the 28
year old Hong Kong was on a business
trip to the neighboring city of Shenzhen
as part of his work for the UK consulate
in Hong Kong he didn't do anything bad
or anything illegal in Simon a China
actually his family members and
girlfriends has been upset throughout
the days because they don't have to
discuss experience before and also I
think they worry about the safety of
Simon the only way to keep him saved is
try to urge the Chinese government to
release him as soon as possible and
gives reasons why Hong Kong people are
going to the mainland China could be
detained the Foreign Office said we are
extremely concerned by reports that a
member of our team has been detained
returning to Hong Kong from Shenzhen we
are providing support to his family and
seeking further information from
authorities in Guangdong province and
Hong Kong that further information
wasn't forthcoming from Beijing we don't
want you fill it in what what I
understand from my sources is that
foreign office staff genuinely don't
know why Simon Chung has been detained
it does make things a lot more
complicated in that UK China
relationship it used to be a golden era
in the days of David Cameron and George
Osborne but since the Hong Kong protests
started that has certainly not been the
case the UK has been commenting and
China doesn't like that at all Beijing
has been pushing back saying this is a
matter for China to sort out don't get
involved so this will make a tricky
relationship even trickier
weeks of protests here in Hong Kong have
unnerved Beijing and strained its
relations with London the British
Foreign Secretary has called on China to
respect peaceful protests today Hong
Kong's chief executive Carrie Lam
attempted to find a way forward one of
the most important strings is a rule of
law that's why we have been doing so
much to ensure that the rule of law is
being upheld and respected in Hong Kong
law may rule in Hong Kong but it works
differently in China
that's exactly why protests began to
reject an extradition treaty to the
mainland
Simon Chung is now apparently at the
mercy of that system
Tom Cheshire Sky News panco